et ben je suis devenu un avatar un
avatar numérique je suis parti dans le
métabère c'est ça y est je suis venu
avatar alors je peux vous regarder droit
dans les yeux ou faire de grands sourire
eh je suis un avatar alors en fait je
vous explique c'est une technologie
c'est une boîte qui fait ça qui
s'appelle complaisance et qui va venir
scanner votre visage alors vous prenez
des photos comme ça tac tac de votre
visage de tous les côtés de face oh bah
on a mes cheveux maman comme vous le
cheveu maman j'ai un bout du crâne mais
je suis là et pour avoir votre avatar
virtuel alors bon vous voyez il y a
encore deux trois trucs qui sont pas
complètement parfait mais ça vient de
m'appeler mon visage ça vient
reconnaître mes expressions faciale vous
voyez mes trucs un petit peu dingue et
puis surtout une fois de plus si vous
voulez avoir un avatar que vous voulez
garder dans le temps vous voulez
continuer comme ça avoir la même tête
durant des années pour avoir un avatar
numérique vous voulez juste pas montrer
votre tronche parce que vous n'êtes pas
levé vous n'êtes pas brosser les dents
et vous avez pas très frais comptable et
bien vous pouvez le faire grâce à votre
avatar numérique et ça c'est cool voilà
donc dites moi si c'est une techno qui
pourrait vous intéresser dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez bien évidemment dans
les commentaires et puis moi je continue
à rester dans mes travers